This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. If you're a parent, you've probably told your kids a thousand times, your room is a mess, clean it up. Managers tell their employees to get organized. Here in the United States, we elect presidents to go clean up Washington. In the next half of our show today, we explore a very different idea. What happens if we treat chaos as our friend instead of our enemy? Tim Hartford believes we should do just that. He's the author of Messy, the power of disorder
to transform our lives. He joined us recently for a live taping. We were just blocks from the White House at NPR's Weekend in Washington. It's an annual event that brings together public radio fans and supporters. Tim Hartford, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. I want to begin by playing you a piece of music come about? What's the story? It's beautiful, isn't it? Two of my children were born to that. It was played by Keith Jarrett, great jazz pianist, in 1975 in Cologne. And if you had been there two or three hours before the concert,
you would not have expected things to go well. Mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio' cylwodio'r cylwodio'r cylwodio yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch the concert because they want a documentary evidence of what a musical catastrophe sounds like, so they could play it to future promoters to tell them to do a good job and get a proper piano. But in fact, it's a masterpiece. It's Keith Jarrett's most popular work. In fact, it's the best selling jazz album in history, solo jazz album in history, and the best-selling piano album in history is the Column Concert. And the surprising thing is that all the adjustments that Jarrett had to make to cope with this bad piano made the music better. So we avoided the harsh upper registers, he stuck to the middle of the keyboard, that makes it sound very soothing. But he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet, so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass to try to get some resonance. And he also had to compensate for the fact that piano was so quiet so he had these rolling repetitive riffs in the bass
to try to get some resonance and he also just stood up and pounded down on the keys so you can hear him moaning in frustration during the concert he's hating it but it is amazing And that combination of the peacefulness and the dynamism makes this electrifying piece of music. So he did not expect that a bad piano would produce a great concert, but in fact it did. And the argument in my book is very often we're faced with the unplayable piano
and actually we produce something great out of it. You have a number of examples besides Keet Gerrit about how disruptions and inconveniences and surprises can sometimes have paradoxically good effects on us, even though we all try to avoid those disruptions. You talk about commuters for example, who suddenly have to find a new way to work, or scientists who are working on so many projects that they're discombobulated, because
they don't know what they're working on. In many of these cases, you find that disorder and confusion could actually be helpful. Yeah, so in the case of commuters, there was a transport strike in London a couple of years ago. Shutdown,r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a'r transport strike a' a'r transport strike a' a'r trweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n gwybod i'n000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000%
yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000% yw'n 1,000%ch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i'n gweithio'r ymdwch i' One of the things I want to do in this conversation is try and tease apart when messiness can be our friend and when it can be our enemy. There's a reason many of us try and avoid messiness. It's because messiness causes delays. It causes disruptions. You're ending up being late for some things.
And I'm wondering as I read some of the examples in your book, whether it was the case that messiness helps people who actually have a base of preparation. So in other words, Keith Jarrett, he's a professional musician, he's very gifted, he's practiced and he's learned the rules of how to play a proper piano for years and years and years. You placed me before that piano, and what you're going to hear is not genius, what you're going to hear is just a mess. And the reason Keith Jarrett could adapt was because he had the base of knowing the rules to now say I can throw out the rule book and create something brilliant.
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right, Shankar. Is it okay, can I open a big bag of complexity science on you? Absolutely. Okay, so basically, if you are trying to solve a very complex problem, we have various algorithms that try to solve this. And we'll come to the question of skill in a second. a'r ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdyn ymdith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymwyr, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymw, a'r gwaith ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn ymdwch yn yydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gydol yn gyd and you should probably avoid most of that part. And that thing with the pedals, don't do that either. But then he sits down at the piano and then his skill kicks in and he's looking for the incremental improvements.
He's looking for a path to find great music. And he finds it. So yes, you need skill, but the random shocks help. So for all the children who are listening to this podcast, I want to make clear that you're not saying that every time your parent tells you to clean up the room, you should just say, Tim Hartford says, I shouldn't.
Well, I have to say, since writing the book, I have stopped asking my children to clear up their room. And the reason is, the reason is, I read an amazing study that had been conducted by two British psychologist, Alex Haslam and Craig Knight. Mae'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith yn ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymwch ymw peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'r peth yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch, yw'n gwybod ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymwch yn ymw yw'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gwe Nobody should make me a boss, by the way. If I'm ever a boss, I will never impose a clean desk policy. And number two, me and my wife, we kind of are the boss in our house, and I no longer ask my children to tidy their rooms. And you know what? We don't argue about it as much. And the rooms are kind of as messy as they ever were.
It hasn't made any difference to the physical state of the rooms. It's just a little bit more peace. All right, so that's a perfect segue to what I want to talk about next, because I actually want to talk about office space and how we organize office spaces. And in fact, I have a clip from the cult classic movie, Office Space, which I'm going to play for you. Hi, Milton. What's happening? I'm sorry.
I'm going to have to ask you to go ahead and move your desk again So if you could go ahead and get it as far back against that wall as possible that would be great No, no, because I was that way. We'll have some room for some of these Boxes and things we need to put in here There it is what here. Let me just go ahead and get that front. Great. So, if you could just get to that as soon as possible, that would be terrific. Okay. Thanks a bunch, Melden.
Bye. Okay. I can sit and building on fire. So I take a tim that you're not a fan of fascist office managers, but you do also tell the story in the book about Steve Jobs at Pixar and some of the ideas he had about how to organize office space to make people more collaborative and some of the ways that might have backed fire. Yeah, the Pixar story I think is fascinating. So Steve Jobs, majority shareholder at Pixar, had a big hand in designing the Pixar building.
And one of his big ideas is we are going to make all the bathrooms in this building in the middle of the building. We're just going to have two big restrooms, a pair of restrooms in the heart of the building. And what that will do is everyone will come together, brought together by a shared yn ymwch i'n gweithio, ac mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio. Ym'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio, a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio' I know this sounds like a great idea on paper, Mr. Jobs, but I need to go to the restroom three times an hour. And you've just made the restroom 10 minutes away from my desk and do the maths. And it's not going to work. And Steve Jobs did an amazing thing. He backed down. He said, OK, I'm wrong.
I will find another way to create Serendipitous Interactions. And you can have your restrooms all over the Pixar offices, which is where they are. Mae'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwaith yw'n gwybod yw'r gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybodbod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn gwybod yn g of control over. It looks like a total mess. In other words, it looks like your children's rooms. Yeah, maybe slightly more creative than my children's rooms, but my children aspire towards the whole Disney Castle thing. Tim Hartford comes from Britain. We're having this chat in the United States. In both countries, there have been enormous political upheavals recently.
When we come back, I'm going to ask Tim about messiness in public life and in democracy. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. With Brexit and the election of Donald Trump term, we've had populous revolutions on both sides of the Atlantic that reject the advice of scientists and economists, experts in general. Democracy, of course, is famously messy. Could you remind people why it's such a good thing? Yes. I think in both cases, I try to remind myself
of Keith Jarrett's unplayable piano, actually. To me, the Brexit vote felt like an unplayable piano. The expert consensus in the UK was that this was not a very good idea. i'n unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r unrhyw i'r ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn ymdyn yn y frustrated, but we should then say, OK, how is this going to make me stronger? How is this going to make my society stronger? What are the solutions that are going to come out of disappointment? Donald Trump ran a campaign that many people thought was extremely disordered. He didn't listen to the experts.
He went off script all the time. He said things that people said would be sure to make him lose. Now your book came out only a few weeks ago, but clearly he must have read an early draft. I, tonight leaking the book to Donald Trump. However, you're absolutely right, there is a section in the book about Donald Trump's campaigning style that was written before he won the election and it was published before he won the election. yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn yng Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwybod yn Nghymru'r gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gwaithio'r ydym yn yw i'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaithio'r gwaith understand what's going on, but at least Bonson Noble are more confused than we are. And as long as Bonson Noble are more confused than we are, we're doing okay. He was very, very clear about this and it has proved very effective.
I want to talk about another example of messiness in public life and I want you to watch this video which describes a very famous speech and I want to ask the question right after it. We can never be satisfied as long as our children are stripped of their selfhood and robbed of their dignity by sign stating for white's own name. We cannot be satisfied as long as a Negro in Mississippi cannot go and a Negro in New York believes he has nothing for which to go. So as you can see from that speech, Tim, Martin Luther King is reading from a script. And he has some nice line there, but it's a right early line. But at a certain point in this speech, he decides to leave the
script behind and turn his eyes to the audience, and here's what we see after that. I still have a dream. It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. I have a dream. But one day, this nation will rise up and live out the true meaning of its creed. We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created. Talk about this for a second, because you talk about this speech in the book, and you
talk about this moment when King left his notes behind and essentially stepped off the ledge of what he knew and what he was certain about and just rode the wave of what the crowd was telling him and what he was feeling. He had prepared that speech meticulously the night before, but it stayed up very late. He was operating on a number of constraints. It was quite a tight time schedule. The eyes of the world were on him, he knew that. Yn gyd ymdwyr yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn ffyrddol yn fio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith looked and he realized it's not working. It's now let us go back to our communities as members for the Society for Creative Disatisfaction. He doesn't say it. He says instead, go back to Alabama. Go back to Alabama, go back to South Carolina, go back to Georgia, go back to Louisiana,
go back to the slums and get holes in our northern cities. And there's another pause, and the people behind him on the stage know he's not on the script anymore. And Mahalia Jackson, great gospel singer, yells out to him because she's heard him talking in church about this dream. She yells out, tell him about the dream Martin. And then he starts to improvise. And that is when he touches the crowd. I want to wrap by asking you a few personal questions. I understand that after writing this book,
every time you find yourself in a mess and you turn to your wife for comfort, she now reminds you that being in a mess is a good thing. Yeah. Actually, just two days ago, Shankar, I was trying to check into a hotel, a Dublin airport, midnight, knowing that I was going to have to get up very early in the morning and fly and then come over to Washington to speak to you. Just desperate to get that little bit of sleep that I would be able to get.
When I showed up at the airport hotel, they didn't have my reservation. And they were full. a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gfeelu'r yw'r pethu'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ymwyr i'r ywy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r fwy'r f and that's a problem for us. Tim Hartford, thank you for joining me today. Thank you, Shaka. Today's show was produced by Chris Benderef, Maggie Pennman, Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clark and Raina Cohen. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our intern is Chloe Connelly. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and subscribe to our weekly podcast. Each week on Hidden Brain, we name an unsung hero, someone who works behind the scenes,
but doesn't always get the recognition they deserve. Our unsung hero this week is Karleen Watson. Karleen is the executive producer of all things considered, and she's been a wonderful resource as hidden brain has grown and taken on different forms. Her sharp editorial judgment and kind support are equally invaluable. Thanks Karleen. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. Trunkervet Anthem and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.